bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur socialos aujourd'hui je vais poser
la question de la représentation des
combattants kurdes au cinéma et
notamment dans le cinéma européen ou
occidental au sens large du terme
en fait elles sont souvent des vins
comme des combattants féministe et bad
ass et si en fait un billet sociologique
à tout ça évidemment c'est essentiel de
montrer au cinéma le combat des kurdes
et notamment des femmes kurdes dans les
mises armée contre l'état islamique
c'est essentiel parce que c'est un
combat qui est fait non seulement on
vous protéger leurs peurs leurs terres
mais un combat qui clairement nous a
tous protégés d'une menace qui est le
terrorisme et c'est une réalité qui est
assez difficile à comprendre parce que
s'inscrire dans des combats très long
dans le fait que les lectures sont
étalées sur plusieurs territoires
nationaux que ils ne vivent pas la
veille en dentelle et donc pas d'armé et
que justement certains groupes armés
kurdes soient qualifiés par des
gouvernements européens de tourisme
donc c'est vrai que c'est vraiment un
enjeu politique aussi de montrer cette
réalité et pour autant ce n'est pas
parce que cette représentation est
nécessaire et qu'elle est utile qu'elle
est parfaite
la sociologie nous n ici à comprendre
quelles sont les limites de cette
représentation des femmes combattants
kurdes au cinéma pour aujourd'hui je
vais me concentrer sur la fiction et
vous montrer que quand on montre au
cinéma des combattants kurdes
eh bien il ya aussi un billet alors il
ya quatre points que je vais aborder
avec vous aujourd'hui
le premier c'est le mythe du jadis curé
peur d'être tués par les femmes alors
c'est quelque chose que l'on attend
beaucoup j'ai un truc que même les gens
qui ne connaissent pas trop les affaires
des kurdes etc ont déjà entendu cette
phrase quand coheris penseraient que se
sont tus par une femme ne pourrait pas
accéder au paradis et notamment soi
disant aux femmes vierges et qu'ils y
trouveraient et chaud que c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment rappeler dans
tous les films sur les combattants qui
ont vraiment il ya toujours un moment un
personnage ou une voix narrative qui va
rappeler ce fait que ces femmes elles
sont super forts parce que
en plus de combattre et tu déjà dit
c'est merci elle les tue ils ne font pas
ce mardi donc comme si james tupper de
ces femmes kurdes et en fait sur moi sa
partie par une forme d' imaginaires
sexiste pourquoi parce que ça a changé
le quintette féminin la combattante
on n'a pas seulement une personne qui
combat on a une femme des combats et qui
de part sa féminité à une arme en plus
soit disant et c'est là où j'ai un
problème c'est que c'est comme si à
cette combattante elle ne voulait pas se
suffire en elle même d'être une femme
qui a pris les armes pour défendre son
peuple grande menace non il faut qu'elle
soit en plus une forme d' armes
idéologiques de contre l'obscurantisme
de l'état islamique
une femme se bat et elle peut leur faire
peur et c'est le deuxième point qui boit
vraiment le plus important c'est que
l'on nous montrent dans tous les films
sur les factures les combattantes comme
des femmes féministes forte etc mais
elle sont dénuées d'histoire en fait ce
sont déterministe sans histoire alors
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là
en fait on nous montre les femmes du
regain des femmes par la plus ouverte
d'esprit beaucoup plus féministe que les
autres peuples de la région et c'est
heureux mais on ne montre jamais les
raisons historiques et politiques qui
ont mené à ce féminisme
il ya là l'idée que les combattants
kurdes ont pris les armes un peu par la
force des choses prises pendant les
films le point de départ de l'histoire
c'est l'héroïne qui est une innocente
villageoise qui est enlevée et violée
par un monde les excès annick et qui
ensuite arrive à s'échapper et donc
rejoint à les milices armées et proenza
et ça c'est quelque chose qui pose
question parce que ça veut dire mais ces
femmes si elles pouvaient elles ne
seraient pas là elle serait à tout ça
fait du shopping que sèche et que c'est
vraiment ma force des choses qu'elles
sont devenues qu'on attente
sauf que pour le peuple kurde il y a une
histoire de lutte armée qui est très
longue
ça fait des décennies que les kurdes
sont organisées avec groupes
paramilitaires dans les différentes
régions où ils vivent et ils sont
d'ailleurs en tension si ce n'est en
guère signé avec le gouvernement de leur
pays et donc
faire croire que les femmes ont pris les
armes
par la force des choses face à la menace
de l'état islamique c'est un mensonge
le point suivant que je me les mettre en
avant ses actions de l'agentivité des
combattantes la question de l'agentivité
en sociologie c'est un concept qui en
fait mais en version le libre arbitre
d'une personne d'un individu le fait
qu'il puisse faire ses choix pour
lui-même et dans la sociologie critique
notamment post colonialiste il ya
vraiment cet aspect de se dire est ce
que là on est en train de montrer la
personne avec ton agent tivité c'est à
dire là tout son livre et dans les films
sur les kurdes il a même souvent ce
billet européen qui a fait qu'on voit
ces femmes sous un prisme occidental
c'est à dire que dans tous ses films
alors on est censé voir comment se
battent ces femmes comment elle en
arrive là
quelles sont les difficultés qu'elles
rencontrent quelles sont leurs rêves
leurs espoirs etc
mais en fait on l'a souvent un
personnage européen qui vient biaisé
l'histoire et qui en fait est au centre
de l'intrigué et on voit les brome
attendent à travers les yeux de cette
personne et c'est un peu le même
problème dans les films documentaires ou
le journaliste va se mettre un trou au
centre de l'histoire c'est à dire que
tout est décalé on va pas donner la
parole directement au conte d'attentes
mais on va d'abord va passer par le
biais tout cas par exemple dans le film
les filles du soleil
emmaüs 1 on a vraiment ce personnage de
la journaliste française qui devient la
voix narrative principal de films alors
que nous on est venu voir un film sur
les combattants kurdes
sapho final que dans ses films tout est
vu depuis l'occident depuis le prisme
européen occidental et qu'on appelle à
vous voir en elle même de ces femmes
kurdes qui s'élève ya plusieurs ouvrages
universitaires qui parle de sujets
décalés le regard avec le prisme
occidental
je voulais me rendre à 20 ans et le
dernier point que je voulais aborder et
pas des moindres ses actions de la
sexualisation des combattantes au cinéma
dans tous les films que j'ai vus il a
toujours un moment où on rappelle que
les femmes combattantes ne sont pas
censés avoir de relations sexuelles ou
sentimentale avec d'autres membres de
l'armée
et il ya souvent me rappelle que c'est
la même chose que ce soit dans le
bataillon hommes dans les batailles ans
a en fait c'est cette figure un truc à
sexualisé de la combattante qui est même
rappelé avec certaines scènes on voit
que les femmes où m'attendait devant le
droit de s'asseoir avec les hommes de
prendre le café etc
alors que c'était quand même assez
encore conservatrice et religieuse
parfois houleux fameuse herbe s'en
séparer donc on a d'abord ces figures
très asexué de la combattante qui vient
très vite se confronter un événement qui
est la combattante tombe amoureuse on a
un rappel de la sexualité de ces femmes
combattantes qui pour moi pensent
vraiment rouler c'est à dire qu'on n'est
pas capable de faire un film où on
montre juste des femmes qui combattent
des femmes qui sont engagés à 100% pour
la défense de leurs peuples de leurs
droits de leur liberté est en fait pour
la protection du monde contre la menace
terroriste
non on est obligé de faire venir un
personnage masculin souvent en plus à un
européen qui vient en fait draguer ou du
moins il va y avoir un coup de foudre
entre une combattante et oui et donc là
là des scènes dénudées de sexualité et c
est pour moi la tous ces films passe
totalement à côté du sujet en voulant
montrer le côté romantique des
combattantes en face on en perd la force
politique de réaction et je trouve ça
fou quand même pas juste accepter que
peut-être que en effet c'est pas mal
hein pas de relation amoureuse
sentimentale avec des hommes enfin je
demande vraiment pourquoi les
réalisateurs et réalisatrices en faisant
de tomber comme ça dans la romance à
outrance
alors que c'est pas du tout le sujet du
film et pourquoi est-ce qu'on doit
toujours dénudée va montrer leur
sexualité en fait les ramener à leur
corps de femmes alors que là elle ce
sont des militaires clairement des vins
qui sont en tournée pour combattre pour
tuer et c'est une réalité tout autre et
la romance n'a rien à faire là dedans
donc voilà pour moi les quatre grands
problèmes qu'il ya avec la
représentation des femmes kurdes au
cinéma j'espère que ça vous aura
intéressé et que vous ne regarderez plus
cette finale même façon avec un air un
peu plus critique en tout cas merci
d'avoir gagné cette vidéo et à bientôt
sur ceux sur le bus
[Musique]